Generally speaking, if you're watching
something with a teen character,
they're likely being played by an
adult actor. There are many reasons
for this—but some castings truly push
the boundaries of believability. Here
are some of the most notable cases of
grown adults playing high schoolers.
Beverly Hills 90210's cast was a mixed
bag of teens and adults when the show
first premiered in 1990. The characters
were supposed to be sophomores in high
school during the first season, so a range
of 15 to 17 would have been realistic.
But most of the cast members were already
in their upper teens when the show began.
Tori Spelling was 17 when she started out
as Donna Martin, as was Brian Austin Green,
who was actually playing a
freshman as David Silver.
Shannen Doherty and Jason Priestley, who played
fraternal twins, Brenda and Brandon Walsh,
were 20 and 21 years old—while bad boy
Dylan was played by the late Luke Perry,
who was a whopping 25 at the time.
The most shocking casting, however, was that
of Gabrielle Carteris as Andrea Zuckerman.
The character is supposed to be super
smart and way more mature than her peers:
Andrea focuses on getting ahead
academically instead of partying.
But Carteris was 29 years old when she
signed on to play 16-year-old Andrea.
According to reports, Carteris lied about her age
and told the casting director she
was "over 21" when she auditioned.
But in the show's fifth season,
Carteris' real-life pregnancy forced
the writers to incorporate the pregnancy
into Andrea's storyline, which led to the
character's eventual exit from the show.
When Party of Five premiered in 1994, the main
characters consisted of 24-year-old eldest brother
Charlie, played by Matthew Fox, 16-year-old
Bailey, played by Scott Wolf, Julia, 15, played
by Neve Campbell, 11-year-old Claudia, played by
actress Lacey Chabert, and baby Owen, age one.
Chabert was obviously in the
same age range as her character,
as was baby Owen. But Campbell was 21
when the series began, and Fox was 28.
Scott Wolf was 26 when he landed the role
of Bailey—a full 10 years older than his
character. Bailey was a rebellious
teen who took on more responsibility
after the Salinger parents
were killed in a car accident.
Later in the storyline, Wolf's
character deals with alcoholism,
and pulls away from his family. Bailey's
arc is defined by his relationship with
his on-again-off-again girlfriend Sarah,
played by Jennifer Love Hewitt. In the end,
perhaps Wolf's maturity helped him capture
the essence of his Bailey counterpart.
Dawson's Creek had quite a few teenagers among
its original cast when it first aired in 1998.
Many of the characters were
high school sophomores. And
a majority of those starring roles went
to actors of a pretty close age range.
Michelle Williams was 17 when she
played the 16-year-old Jen Lindley,
15-year-old Dawson was played by 20-year-old
James Van Der Beek, and 15-year-old Pacey and
16-year-old Joey were played by a 19-year-old
Joshua Jackson and 18-year-old Katie Holmes.
But then the McFee siblings arrived and
threw off Dawson's age-appropriate groove.
"I've always been this complete klutz. Some
things never change." "No. Everything changes."
In season two, Jack and
Andie McFee joined the gang
and all those teenage hormones were
interrupted by 20-something shenanigans.
Actor Kerr Smith was 26 when he stepped
onto the set of Dawson's Creek as Jack.
The record, however, goes to Meredith Monroe, who
was 28 years old when she started playing Andie.
Both siblings are supposed to be just 16.
On Fox's musical high school comedy Glee,
it might as well have been a requirement
to be an adult playing a teenager. Most
actors were significantly older than the
teenage characters they were playing:
Lea Michele was 23 when she took on 15-year-old
Rachel Berry, as were Mercedes actor Amber Riley
and Quinn actor Dianna Agron. Heather Morris and
Naya Rivera were both 22 when the show began.
The only one whose age still ended as
a teen was 19-year-old Chris Colfer,
whose character Kurt is supposed to be 16.
But the biggest age gap goes to the late Cory
Monteith, who was 27 years old when he was cast
as the 15-year-old Finn Hudson. Sure, Monteith
seemed young, but not as young as an actual
15-year-old. With the incredible shooting
and rehearsal demands of a show like Glee,
it's not surprising the producers went
with actors who were all over 18—so
that they didn't have to deal with
any minor-centric acting laws.
Monteith's age afforded him a
unique wealth of life experience,
especially when compared to some of his
castmates. Before he broke into Hollywood,
Monteith had worked as a Walmart greeter,
roofer, cab driver, and school bus driver.
As is the case with so many shows, all of the
kids on Gilmore Girls were played by adults.
When the show started out, Rory, played by
Alexis Bledel, and her pals are sophomores
in high school. Bledel was 19 while
playing her 16-year-old character,
by far the show's most reasonable age match.
Her main love interests are 16-year-old Dean,
played by an 18-year-old Jared Padalecki, and
15-year-old Jess, played by a then 23-year-old
Milo Ventimiglia . Rory's 16-year-old nemesis
Paris was played by 23-year-old Liza Weil.
You might think those 23-year-old actors are
pushing it. But the president of the "too old for
school" club on Gilmore Girls has to be Rory's
BFF Lane Kim, who was played by Keiko Agena.
"If you could live in any city in
the world you pick Philadelphia?"
"M. Night Shyamalan lives there." "Who?"
"The guy who directed The Sixth Sense."
At the time, Agena was 27. With Lorelai Gilmore
being 32, played by a 33-year-old Lauren Graham,
the actor playing Lane was closer in age to her
best friend's mom than she was to her best friend.
We can't say Agena didn't pull it off—her
Lane is full of youthful exuberance.
But there's something undeniably funny about
Graham and Agena being real-world peers,
playing a mom and a young girl on TV.
Buffy the Vampire Slayer began in 1997 with main
characters who are supposed to be sophomores in
high school. Buffy, played by Sarah Michelle
Gellar, was 19 playing a 16-year-old. Willow,
her witchy best-friend-forever, is also 16,
and was played by 19-year-old Alyson Hannigan.
Nicholas Brendon was much older, at 26, than
his sophomore character, Xander. The oldest
member of the cast was David Boreanaz, who,
at 35, was playing vampire-with-a-soul Angel,
who is supposed to be about 20 ... or
like 250, depending on how you look at it.
But the oldest actor playing an actual teenager
was Charisma Carpenter, who at 27 took on the
role of Cordelia Chase, yet another sophomore.
When Cordelia leaves the Scooby gang in season
three for the cast of Angel, they bumped her up
in age a bit, so that it didn't feel so awkward.
We'll give you one guess as to how old the
characters in Riverdale are supposed to be.
If you guessed sophomores in high school, you win!
The cast of Riverdale features a whole
gang of actors in their early 20s playing
characters who are supposed to be 15 or 16
years old. The only actual teen is KJ Apa,
who was 19 when the show started out. The other
actors—Lili Reinhart, Ross Butler, Camila Mendes,
Ashanti Bromfield, Madelaine Petsch, Cole Sprouse
and Casey Cott—all range in age from 20 to 26.
But the eldest member of the
Riverdale gang is Ashleigh Murray,
who was 30 when she started playing teen
rocker Josie, of Josie and the Pussycats.
"They were from your father's gang weren't they?"
This means that Murray is old enough to have been
the target audience for the 2001
Josie and the Pussycats movie.
How's that for perspective?
Zombie apocalypse drama The Walking Dead isn't a
teen show, though a lot of teens count themselves
as fans. It's a show full of grown adults
fighting for their lives. Occasionally,
however, kids and teens become entangled
in the violent, bloody fight for survival.
One character of note is Carl, lead character
Rick Grimes' son, who grows from being a kid
to a teen throughout the series. But aside
from Carl's actor, Chandler Riggs, there
aren't many teen actors on the show. Much like
other shows in which adults are cast as teens,
The Walking Dead probably did so because of
the series' super-demanding shooting schedule.
The most popular teen on The Walking
Dead has likely been Beth Greene,
fan-favorite Hershel's youngest daughter.
Beth appears in seasons two through five,
and is supposed to be about 16 years old.
In reality, Beth was played by Emily Kinney,
who was 26 years old when she was on
the series. Beth's death is a sad one,
since the character is so sweet and kind, but
hey—them's the breaks on The Walking Dead.
Smallville tells the story of Superman's high
school days in the Kansas town he grew up in.
Though the young Clark is supposed to
be 14 years old when the show begins,
the lead actor, Tom Welling, was 24
years old at the time. But really,
does age matter when aliens
and superheroes are at play?
Superman Returns, starring Brandon
Routh, debuted in 2006—smack
in the middle of Smallville's run. Returns
centers around a grown-up Superman,
well into his cape-wearing years, dealing
with mature issues of romance and his career.
Yet Routh was three years younger than Welling,
then playing Clark Kent as a high schooler.
By the time the show wrapped up, Welling
was 34 years old. Throw in a 29-year-old
Michael Rosenbaum playing a 21-year-old Lex
Luthor, and you've got one "geriatric" cast.
Of the four main characters on The O.C., only
one started out the show as an actual teenager.
Mischa Barton was 17 years
old when the series began,
only a blip older than her character Marissa, who
is, you guessed it, a sophomore in high school.
Other leads like Seth and Summer were played by
23-year-old Adam Brody and
21-year-old Rachel Bilson.
The oldest member of The
O.C. cast was Ben MacKenzie,
who was 24 when he started playing Ryan
Atwood. Bad boy Ryan is supposed to be
the new guy in town who shows the rich kids
of The O.C. how to misbehave and have a good
time. At least MacKenzie's age gave his
bad-boy vibe a little more believability.
Veronica Mars premiered in 2004 with Kristen
Bell playing high school private detective
Veronica. In a major departure from teen-show
tradition, Veronica Mars is actually a junior
when the show begins. The second season
follows her senior year, while the third
chronicles Veronica's freshman year at the
fabulously named Neptune's Hearst College.
Bell was already well into her 20s when the show
began. In 2004, she was 24 years old, making her
about seven years older than the character.
By the time the series wrapped, she was 27.
"I'm heading out of town and
I'm not sure when I'll be back."
The Veronica Mars film that debuted in
2014 sees the Neptune High gang attend
their 10-year high school reunion, even though
their graduation was in 2006. The fourth season,
which hit Hulu in 2019, is set in that year,
with Veronica presumably around age 32,
again played by Bell at the age of 39.
All things considered, Veronica Mars should
be proud of itself. Few teen shows could have
handled such a disjointed, decade-spanning
existence with as much smoothness as it did.
Fonzie isn't a high-schooler on Happy Days, but
he does start out as a teenager. The 1970s series
created by the late Garry Marshall is set in the
1950s, starring Ron Howard as Richie Cunningham,
an average high school kid in the Midwest.
His best friend—and the Cunningham's tenant,
who lives above the garage—is Arthur Fonzarelli,
AKA Fonzie or The Fonz, played by Henry Winkler.
Fonzie starts out the show at 19 years old, but
Winkler was already way into his 20s when the show
began. At 29, the actor was a full
decade older than his character,
a high school dropout who is seen as the bad
boy of the very traditional 1950s setting.
Fonzie proves them all wrong, however, when he
earns his high school diploma via night school,
eventually becoming a teacher. By the
time Happy Days ended, Winkler was 39!
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.